Myanmar is booming almost every week a
new product hits the market or a new
infrastructure project is announced but
starting new businesses takes time until
2012 this restaurant owned by a public
official son had the only good internet
connection in Rangoon it's where nae al
started his online travel agency in
terms of the internet across the country
you don't have a good finance sector
where payment can be made and it was
very difficult to recruit initially
today the ohwe company employs 160
people and is one of Myanmar's biggest
travel agencies al who studied in
Silicon Valley wants to use his work in
the online travel industry to help
transform the country's electronic and
mobile payment system since Myanmar
opened up to the outside world 1 million
tourists visit the country each year the
market is enormous property prices in
Rangoon have reached record highs as
colonial-era buildings make way for
modern architecture south korean car
maker honda is active here along with
samsung and coca-cola has opened up a
production plant mobile networks are
rapidly expanding here and smartphone
sales have gone through the roof in 2012
yet men gave up his studies in Singapore
to found a start-up in Rangoon his
breakthrough came with hush a chat
application that allows users to remain
anonymous freedom of speech was long
suppressed in Myanmar we thought that
you know maybe people are scared to talk
about it because there's always
consequences when they talk something so
maybe if we provide them a place where
they don't have any consequences nobody
knows who they are you know
nothing traces back to you that they
would speak more his internet and app
design company next now has 30 employees
the tea house restaurant in Rangoon is
reinterpreting Burmese cuisine the owner
who grew up in England serves
traditional tea house dishes in a modern
atmosphere he wants to preserve Burmese
culture and promote local food producers
I think anyone who comes here you can
see that the potential of this place and
I don't mean the potential just
economy-wise are just infrastructure but
I mean in the people hard-working
passionate the ones who are coming back
are the driven ambitious ones who wants
to do it the future looks bright for me
and mark
experts predict economic growth of at
least 8% over the next decade and a
tripling of GDP by 2030 but first it's
up to the government to implement its
planned economic reforms